salut aujourd'hui c'est l'astuce du jour
alors je ne savais pas quoi vous donner
comme astuce ce mercredi je regardais un
petit peu dans les commentaires les
derniers échanges qu'on a eus ensemble
sur facebook twitter et instagram et
tous les réseaux et vous me demandez
souvent comment on peut faire pour
calculer rapidement un pourcentage
et là je me dis c'est bien qu'on échange
ensemble parce que de moi même je vous
aurais pas fait forcément une vidéo là
dessus alors je vais vous faire une
vidéo très rapide sur ce qu'on appelle
la règle de trois une bonne fois pour
toutes vous allez enfin pouvoir savoir
faire la règle de trois la règle de
trois c'est une règle mathématique qui
permet en fait de calculer tous les
rapports proportionnelle dès qu'on a
deux choses qui sont proportionnelles on
peut calculer un élément manquant sur
ces deux choses pas extrêmement clair ça
hein pas de problème démonstration pour
une règle de trois il faut commencer à
faire des cases
il nous faut quatre cases comme ceci ici
on va mettre les deux premiers éléments
qui sont en lien ici
les deux éléments qu'on recherche par
exemple au moment où je vous parle j'ai
à peu près mille 900 abonnés et je fais
environ 35000 vues par mois ça c'est
beaucoup dans mon monde à moi c'est
beaucoup c'est grâce à vous donc je vous
dis merci au passage maintenant
imaginons qu'à chaque fois que je
demande d'abonnés mais vu augmente à peu
près proportionnellement en tout cas
c'est possible c'est quelque chose que
je peux me dire dans ces cas-là à
combien d'abonnés jeffrey 50000 vues par
mois
et bien si j'applique la règle de trois
il faut que je puisse remplir cette case
là et bien pour le savoir faut que je
remplisse cette case là en utilisant la
règle de tron la règle de trois on me
dit que si je multiplie ses deux cases
là et que je divise par celle ci alors
j'aurai le résultat ici et je peux même
simplifiée en enlevant trois héros ici
et 3 0 ici donc ça fait cinquante fois
1900 / 35 ce qui fait environ 2700 14 et
en utilisant la règle de trois jeux secs
à 2714 abonnés geoffrey en moyenne
cinquante mille vues par mois
si on tient le même rythme faisant un
autre exemple avec quelque chose que
vous connaissez plus que le nombre des
vidéos d'abonnés sur youtube les soldes
intéressants ça les soldes si vous voyez
qu'un manteau il ya un mois
50% vous savez que ça va être à peu près
à moitié prix s'il ya un manteau qui à
-30% vous savez que vous pouvez enlever
à peu près un tiers du prix et si vous
tombez sur une réduction de 47%
comment vous faites déjà vous pouvez
aller voir le gérant du magasin en lui
disant qu'il n'a rien compris à ce qui
était le commerçant fait parce que c'est
pas simple du tout 47 % donc notre
manteau vos 98 euros comme ça ça aide
bien embêtant et il a une réduction de
47% on voudrait connaître le montant de
la réduction donc 100% du prix c'est 98
euros 98 97 jeudi je sais plus bon si
c'est pas ça je change l'exemple ce sera
98 98 et la réduction est de 47% donc on
veut connaître le montant de la
réduction 47%
donc là il faut que je passe 47 x 81 18
/ 100 ça fait à peu près 40 6 euros
je sais qu'il y aura peu près 40 6 euros
de réduction donc qu'il faudrait que je
fasse 80 18 - 46 pour avoir le résultat
mais il ya plus simple encore le plus
simple serait était de connaître
directement le prix final vous êtes
d'accord avec moi alors pour faire ça je
refais mon produit en croit je marque
100%
ici la réduction affichée en magasin et
47% donc je fais sans au moins 47 ça
fait cinquante trois là je mets le prix
98 donc je fais 53 x 90 / sens et ça
nous fait à peu près 50 de petit peu
moins de 52 et ça c'est le prix final de
notre manteau moi c'est plutôt une bonne
affaire je lâche retenez bien en fait
comment ça marche le produit en croit
parce que ça sert tout le temps si fier
s'il ya bien un truc qu'on apprend en
fait et qu'il nous sert tout au long de
notre vie
c'est la règle de trois où le produit en
croit on utilise les deux noms moi ça me
sert pour tous même en voiture ça me
sert c'est à dire que quand je m'ennuie
en voiture je compte je pense que ça ne
vous surprend plus en fait pour
m'occuper mentalement comme je m'ennuie
sur la route je compte par exemple je
regarde mon gps et si je vois que je
suis à 212 km de mon lieu d'arrivée je
vais commencer à calculer la vitesse
moyenne je me dis bon je suis sur une
nationale c'est à 90 km/heure j'ai
traversée des agglomérations à 50
km/heure la moyenne est de 70 donc j'ai
212 km à faire à 70 km heure de moyenne
donc dans combien de temps est-ce que je
vais arriver
bonne question et sans regarder le gps
je sais que je fais 70 km/heure donc 70
km en 60 minutes
on va compter en minutes parce que là
c'est plus simple j'ai 212 km à faire
donc 212 x 60 / 70 ça fait environ 180
ce qui fait environ trois heures puisque
une heure ça fait soixante minutes
et là tout de suite on saura quel point
c'est fun un trajet en voiture avec moi
voilà une bonne fois pour toutes vous
allez savoir faire maintenant un produit
en croit vous allez enfin connaître
cette règle de trois qui est très simple
il suffisait juste qu'on l'expliqué avec
des exemples je vous rappelle vous
faites les quatre cases dans la première
colonne vous allez mettre les deux
informations qui sont liées ensemble
dans la deuxième colonne les deux
informations qui sont encore liés
ensemble dont une des deux que vous ne
connaissez pas que vous cherchez à
trouver ce qui est important c'est que
sur la première ligne on parle bien de
la même chose si c'est des heures ici
c'est des heures ici si ces deux
pourcentages ici ces deux pourcentages
là et pareil pour la deuxième ligne si
c'est un montant c'est un bon temps si
c'est les minutes c'est les minutes ça
doit avoir à chaque fois la même unité
de mesure
bien sûr j'espère que cette astuce du
jour vous a plu en temps normal oui
parce que c'était une de vos demandes
je vous rappelle qu'à 2500 abonnés on va
se faire un live tous ensemble alors on
va faire des choses de mentalist moment
à discuter je vais aussi répondre à vos
questions tout simplement et on va
peut-être se trouver un nom de team
voilà il ya je crois c'est axel qui a
mis ça dans les commentaires pourquoi on
n'avait pas de nom de team pas c'est une
bonne question trouvons un nom de team
on peut faire ça on peut faire ça au
live mais le live ce sera 2500 abonnés
donc pensez à vous abonner à la chaîne
vous avez encore le gros logo car train
d'apparaître avec la fiche des
hallucinations collectives du 28 mars
partager cette vidéo partout sur tous
les réseaux sociaux que tout le monde
sache enfin utiliser cette règle de
trois une bonne fois pour toutes
c'est notre mission c'est notre mission
apprenons la règle de trois tout
internet
rendez vous demain à 17 heures pour le
prochain mentale vlog chaos
plus